-Halle and I are about
to play
a game of Sticky Balls,
which refers, of course,
to these balls
which stick to these
Velcro suits that we're wearing.
We are going to put
45 seconds on the clock
and then throw these
sticky balls at one anothe
until time runs out.
Once we're done,
Halle and I will each coun
the sticky balls
stuck to the other person.
The one with the most ball
stuck to their suits loses
The first ball thrown
has to be
one of the balls
in the center line.
No crossing over
into the other person's court,
and absolutely
no removing of balls
from your suit
once you've been hit.
[ Laughter ]
Are you ready
to play Sticky Balls?
-Yeah, but I don't even
know how you throw balls.
You can't even walk.
-I know, that's half the trick
That's the trick of the game
-It doesn't seem fair.
-Let's assume the position
All right, ready?
[ Drumroll ]
It is hard to walk.
Three, two, one.
Sticky Balls!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[Bleep]
Make sure your hair
don't stick to this.
-Here we go.
-Oh, God.
-All right.
That's it.
Now, Halle,
will you please...
-Want me to take your balls off?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Will you please do me the
pleasure of counting my balls?
[ Laughter ]
[ Drumroll ]
-1, 2, 3...
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9,
10, 11, 12...
13, 14, 15, 16, 17.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-One more, 18.
-18.
-How do you look cute
in this outfit?
I mean, oh, my gosh.
[ Laughter ]
Only you.
All right, ready?
-Yeah.
[ Drumroll ]
-Can I count your balls?
-Count my balls.
I didn't know I had balls.
[ Laughter ]
-1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, 8, 9, 10...
-Oh, God, I'm gonna lose.
-...11, 12, 13, 14...
That one's in there.
...15, 16, 17 --
-Oh, man, I lost.
-...18, 19!
You won.
That is a champ!
[ Cheers and applause ]
The winner!
I love you.
Halle Berry, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]